so I just heard that they broke into the
office of one of my personal attorneys
yesterday we had the FBI raid the
president's attorney's residence and his
business and got information that has
that that's privileged information what
a double standard we see mr. president
attorney-client privilege is alive and
well but there's an exception when the
attorney might be involved in a crime or
fraud it's part of a judicial process we
should let it work its way through well
despite a lot of the day being taken up
by the CEO of Facebook testifying on
Capitol Hill this is still a big story
here in this town and the president is
weighing in on his personal attorney and
the raid on his office and apartment or
hotel room tweeting attorney-client
privilege is dead and a total witch hunt
just a short time ago Michael Cohen that
attorney had a quote to CNN quote I am
unhappy to have my personal residence in
office rated but I will tell you that
members of the FBI that conducted the
search and seizure were all extremely
professional courteous and respectful
and I thank them at the conclusion you
heard some of the pushback of this
action here is Alan Dershowitz this is a
very dangerous day today for lawyer
client relations I deal with clients all
the time I tell them on my word of honor
that what you tell me is sacrosanct and
now they say just based on probable
cause even though this was cooperation
with Cohan they can burst into the
office grab all the computers and then
give it to another FBI agent and say
you're the firewall der schwarze
is at the White House we're told right
now had a meeting with President Trump
and is apparently having dinner with him
let's bring in our panel jonah goldberg
senior editor at national review
moralizing national political
correspondent of national public radio
and matthew cottan Ettie editor-in-chief
of the washington free beacon okay Maura
well this is a investigation that's
getting awfully close to the president I
thought what was really interesting
yesterday is you had some polite
eight pushback from Republicans you had
Mitch McConnell saying the investigation
should go forward you had John Cornyn
saying that Muller's report should
definitely be given to Congress which is
not required
you also had Chuck Grassley saying it
would be suicide to talk about firing
Muller and this comes after people who
are talking to the president outside
advisors are saying that he's as mad as
he's ever been and this the the idea of
possibly firing Jeff Sessions is very
very long sessions rose because that's
the way you get rid of Muller write
really well Rosen Stein or sessions you
have to you have to either replace the
Attorney General with someone who's not
recused fire rod Rosenstein that's the
way you get rid of this but you know
you've heard all kinds of punditry Jonah
about this is a move that's kind of
tangential to the Russia investigation
designed to have the president do what
he's potentially contemplating doing and
that is fire Muller and thereby make the
case for obstruction of justice pretty
clear
yeah but the funny thing about this are
the weird thing about this is that
forget whether it's political suicide or
all those things it would be pointless
to fire Muller because Muller is not
doing the Michael Cohen investigation he
handed it off to the US Attorney for the
Southern District of New York who is not
working for Muller if you fired Muller
the that thing continues to go the only
way to get rid of that investigation is
to fire the Trump appointed interim
director of the US Attorney's Office but
you got to put somebody in there who
will then kill this investigator
politically that is just I mean the
optics of trying to make it make it all
go away now I just think are almost
impossible but maybe I'm wrong it's
important to ask how president from
found himself in this situation to begin
with and that was by firing James Comey
and after commis firing Comey leaked the
memos which then led to the appointment
of the special prosecutor so now if
president from thinks he can fix the
situation by firing the special
prosecutor doesn't make much sense if
the first firing led to only more
problems for him there's one situation
where maybe he could do this if the
Republicans hold on to the House of
Representatives then maybe he could fire
him because if if he fired him now it
would help Democrats I think in the
election and if Democrats took over they
even if Muller was fired they'd probably
have him up testifying seven days a week
Donald Trump has been a disrupter to
Washington he's has everybody reacting
to his actions with one exception
Robert Moeller he's the other disrupter
and the two of them now in combat could
lead to a very combustible situation
well it's definitely combustible
speaking combustible the decision on
Syria we're told is imminent if it's not
already been made and that some action
may be imminent here's the president
today we're making a decision as to what
we do with respect to the horrible
attack that was made near Damascus and
it will be met forcefully we speak today
and we see the suffering of the Syrian
people and me and the president we see
eye-to-eye that this matter has to stop
immediately we can't tolerate with a war
criminal we cannot tolerate was someone
who could more than half a million of
his own people and this matter should
end immediately their meeting in the
Oval Office with the Qatar II
Amir and she remember a short time ago
the president marb said that Qatar was
responsible for supporting terrorism
so quite a turnabout here fast things
change in Trump world whether it's in
foreign policy or ex advisors everything
is pretty fluid and flexible as he likes
to say but we do think that that there
is likely some imminent act I think
there is and to me the question is is it
going to be like what he did exactly
almost exactly a year ago where he hit
an airfield didn't seem to deter them
from using chemical weapons again is it
going to be something more take out the
Syrian Air Force that would risk a
confrontation with Russia you know
what's he gonna do that will actually
have a deterrent effect because the last
thing he did didn't work
John yeah I mean I think John Trump
needs to do something he didn't call it
a redline but by doing it the first time
he basically set a precedent that says
you know if you're gonna the first time
he said there were a lot of red lines I
guess that's right yeah my vote is that
it would be it would be a loss of
credibility for Donald Trump in the
United States if he didn't do it
I think he's gonna do it now and you
should do something now what he does I'm
not sure the real problem for me is
Syria is just looking to be basically
the Balkans of the 21st century with so
many workmen it's not even the Spanish
Civil War anymore which you least had
two sides to it the place is just a hot
mess and how we figure out a strategy
about how to fix the place or do
anything or whether we should even try
or at least minimize the damage is very
difficult to see Russia feels like it is
in their sphere of influence and they
are have a lot more reputation and
political capital invested in the place
and it's a thorny issue to figure out
what we can do about you know Matthew
I've heard different pundits and
different folks question whether this in
fact was Syria who did this
I've talked to a number of officials who
say they have pretty solid evidence and
that they're going to be briefing as
much as they can be on the classified
you heard the president and the Cabinet
Room saying we have a good idea this is
probably going to happen I think so and
I think it's important for president
Trump to understand that the logic of
deterrence means that whatever action he
takes will have to be larger than the
action he took after the attack last
year which I did do you think deterred
Assad for a time until he felt that the
attention was no longer being paid so
the person and the person to the watch
now though is Bolton right who's always
been reluctant about involving us
heavily in the Syrian civil war or
changing the regime but I do not think
is averse to really kind of having the
the full might of the United States
military raining down on the weaponry of
Assad he's also not averse to shaking up
the staff we're told that Tom Basara is
leaving because John Bolton wants his
own people there if you take a look at
the list of notable Trump administration
resignations or firings we are now up to
the number of 31 Tom bustard on the
bottom right hand corner there Homeland
Security Adviser being the latest yeah
this is I don't think this is the same
as Donald Trump firing someone this is
john bolton who as the new national
security adviser gets to have his own
people he got rid of the spokesman for
the national security council and now
the deputy national security adviser he
his own folks there and he's going to
get them happens all the time
lots of cover